Oh
and I want you I want to see you say it
out then we don't have to have everyone
learning the front brake off and it's
also showing your control
- so you really committed cross
a cross turn okay we're gonna let you
have your arms the boss turn here's
here's what you're going to be you guys
see that I know my hip still be here so
draw the X bring the other foot in and
turn your back as much as you can look
up at them have this diagonal in your
back don't feel like this so one and the
hip goes out to turn your body this way
okay have your feet under your hips not
wider okay
let's try just that you're okay so now
I'm going to do that same thing but this
arm is going to go around him and now
you have to torque all that body okay so
the same thing
really get close to you
[Music]
stretch stretch
okay let's try that arm come in get
believe this Center no space knee and
foot alignment and I'm going to extend
my legs as I roll my body looking down
and I'll pick it and it should be
effortless because all we're already
glued we're glued hmm I'm underneath
this Center and I start to extend my
knees and roll my body so I'm looking
down
okay just that little Papa both in the
eyes over remember yep the curve of the
blade and the curve of the spy on the
curve of the movement and all that has
to blend together if it doesn't blend
together your heart is not long enough
your source out a short knob and it gets
stuck all right same very similar thing
a Chiho Nadia we were doing that
recently so if I close them I'm not
going to enter remember there's a tiny
there's a timing the descent happens in
relationship to my ad me it's no
different any DP not yet so I can't go
like this really take displaces body and
I can't go like this it has to be a
timing so timing that it works saving
here so I have the extending of my legs
and then rotation of my button you have
to figure out where those go in relation
to each other because if you extend your
legs now your Center is high and you
can't get it if you leave your legs here
and you turn you're going to get smashed
here so you have to get that timing so
it's just effortless
[Music]
okay again just finally pick them up
good yes so remember enough to leave
your arm behind in this version okay so
don't leave your army or you're doing it
because now you're gonna get space back
here yeah so your arm is going to come
around this on is going to be opposite
of that so this arm is coming around and
this arm is extending until it doesn't
extend anymore it runs a cycle and
that's when I bring it back in okay you
got it so don't don't bring this here
keep it going out
we were back to the one that we tried to
start with
hi extend look down
[Music]
out okay let's go okay this time I'm
gonna come here do this same thing hold
on to this corner you see this corner
right here that's what I'm using if I
come around here everything is the same
I might have to get a little lower
one two three
[Music]
okay try it okay once you get it like
all right you know you start doing it
with less less and less okay less and
less every time
[Music]
Hey